and
you just did a uh interview with that
guy uh john
sweeney and he has a whole podcast
dedicated to
epstein and maxwell and that whole story
right
bbc his podcast became the number one
podcast in the uk
it was really it's called hunting galain
so my interview of him is called hunting
galain maxwell's
john sweeney if people want to check
that out i thought i knew a lot about
maxwell
but he spent many years um dedicated to
that
and i learned a lot from john sweeney
really there were things i was wondering
about and he filled in those blanks
what was the biggest revelation or the
biggest thing that he uncovered in your
mind
so he talked about
maxwell glenn maxwell's upbringing
and he just went into you know a vivid
description
of how dysfunctional it was under robert
maxwell
who was this charismatic media tycoon
but he was also
an absolute monster and a psychopath
in many ways and
because he was so charming people who
were close to him you know when they
said he's like he's a monster he's a
psychopath who said
well at least he's our monster or at
least he's our psychopath
but apparently gillane was subjected to
corporal punishment
and there was a selection of belts and
looking at what happened later on
you know books that were found in
epstein's properties like the marquis de
sade
this bdsm stuff
a lot of what happens to us when we're
kids carries forward into our adult
lives
so this bdsm
propensity it seems that a root cause
is possibly the the the beltings and the
corporal punishment that she got from
her dad who she idolized and he was
her favorite as well out of all of the
kids who
some of them became hugely successful
some of them died there was
all it's like a a a greek tragedy what
happened to the kids
what happened how many brothers and
sisters does she have
um a lot a lot quite let me just have a
look right now
we could see how her behavior was shaped
by the treatment that came from
her father now you know
sweeney was quite sympathetic in respect
that he was saying that that was a
mitigating
circumstance you know for max well
because
of this dysfunctional um upbringing
nine children nine
nine children he had so
if you want to hear the crazy stuff that
happened to these um
these kids so michael was the oldest
brother
he fell into a coma age 15 after a car
crash
in 1961 and died eight years later
having never regained consciousness
so imagine yoga lane and your brother
is just on life support and he can't
even communicate with you
so that is really sad eight years
eight years philip 71
poor phillip he was described by as his
friends became a brilliant scientist and
mathematician won a scholarship to
barely all college oxford at just 16
but he so hated his father
that as soon as he could he fled to
argentina to get as far away from him as
possible
they fell out when he married nilda an
argentinian in 1977 against his dad's
wishes
the marriage didn't last nilda moved out
taking their daughter marcella
with her the second marriage also failed
he was last heard of living in a 65
pound a week
flat that is a hundred dollar a week
apartment in north london trying to be a
writer
and what was he writing about his
bullying father
anne 69
became an actress and she was called
ugly
by her father god
when her fledgling acting career
floundered
her dad said what have you and pope john
paul ii
got in common you are both ugly and
you're both
failed actors this is how crazy that guy
was
jesus christ she studied italian in
french oxford
trained at a as a montessori teacher
married an osteopath
and is now believed to be a hypnotist in
surrey practicing under a different name
she kept out of the limelight since her
father's definitely 68 so i'm
sorry i might try and get a hold of her
oh this is a good one
christine so you saw some of them um
didn't do very well but these did
christine and her sister isabelle made
the sunday times rich list in 1999 after
amassing
a hundred million pounds during the
dot-com bubble
but then they lost it all but now
they're back up again or something it's
crazy
jeez man yeah yeah uh where where are
they all
where was the uh what was the dad's name
again robert maxwell
robert maxwell where was he where where
did he live where was he based at was he
in the
uk so he was out of czechoslovakia
oh okay and his entire family were wiped
out in the holocaust
but his mum said to him get to england
and copy the mannerisms of an english
gentleman
and that's what he did interesting
oh those is a weird death isabel the
second twin
she um
got together with an illusionist
a third husband illusionist al seckel
a significant player in the california
literary academ academic and
celebrity scene was famous for holding
parties for the great and good
and was a good friend of epstein
in 2009 the two organized a science
conference called mind shift on
epstein's private island
isabel and settle married in malibu in
2007
but the union was never legal as he had
forgotten to file the papers to another
second of three previous marriages
um but here's what happens to him
um in 2015
sekkel was found dead below a cliff
near their home in the village of saint
circ
la papi in france's valley
and isabelle still lives in the south of
france was he epstein in 2015
somebody needs hbo needs to do a
documentary on the maxwell family
that's going to be [ __ ] bonkers
here's an even sadder one
karine the middle sister
aged free in 1957.
died of leukemia oh
hold on it goes man it's endless the
sister yeah yes
it's a tragic tragic history from that
family
kevin became britain's biggest ever
bankruptcy
on and on it goes yeah wow
you